Let's go next to our caller from the three
one seven area code. Who's calling today from
three one seven?
Hello, David. This is Linda and that just
started recently watching you and thank you
so much for last night. Help me get through
the.
We left and I did want to put that out there.
Thank you. Would have made it. Really made
it. Listen, I barely made it through the RNC.
I didn't hear you say.
I was barely able to make it through the Republican
convention.
I know. And the night before I did watch and
I was like I was flipping through this in
trying to figure out what I want to say is
that I'm new to all of this.
I never was one to be in politics. Do you
feel now you know impolitely it's like I moved.
So my bleep with you know, I'm just so scared
that we're gonna wake up one morning and we're
going to have our soldiers on our soil because
it is still five weeks in in the country.
It's scary.
It's like I used to be so proud to be an American,
a black American, a noun.
You know, I'm getting to the point where.
I had heard a caller ask, what is the worst
case scenario?
A hangup is pretty much my answer. Worst case
scenario was what my nightmare has been. So
my question is, with him doing all of this
where he is constantly breaking the law and.
Not abide by the rules.
Why don't they? And I'm coming to this right
now. And just learning. Why can't they all
get together and put him out with even no
one? The next four years. What with him being
in office again? Why? Why don't they just
play in the White House out with all of these
people and kids move around? Why is he even
able to even run for president again?
OK. Under. So, Linda, here, this is a great
question. So when you say why don't why don't
they just remove him? Who's the they you're
talking about?
The that is a lot of Republicans, I'm sure
they're there. You're a Democrat. It seems
like they're scary.
I don't understand why they don't the politicians
don't get together and remote. You know, I
did hear why would we even allow a even running
game with everything going on?
OK, so let me explain that this is a good
question, because it's you're coming into
this and you're applying logic to a situation
that's not logical. So. Trump was impeached
by Democrats in the House and then there was
a trial in the Senate. There is a majority
of Republicans in the Senate and and the Republicans
decided they weren't going to convict Donald
Trump. So the reason they didn't do it is
because they don't want to. It's political.
Republicans have decided either it would be
bad for them or it would be bad for their
party or whatever, or they don't think Trump
did anything wrong. So that the Democrats
can't remove him because you would have to,
through impeachment, convict in the Senate.
Republicans have a majority. They voted to
acquit. You could then remove Trump via the
25th Amendment if Trump's cabinet determined
that he
was unfit to serve. There'd be a special mechanism
under the 25th Amendment to remove him. Republicans
at Trump's cabinet don't want to do it. So
this is how we end up at Linda.
That in 10 weeks we can remove him if we vote
him out. That's the way we do it.
OK. I'm doing everything I can, my little
phase, I tried to do so nay in influence in
my family, the vote, but we got a vote like
we've never voted before. Yes. I just encourage
everyone listening to this. Please vote. Get
it out there. Tell your family as we do. And
that was another question. If there. How how
does our vote count? If they are saying like
Surrell both. Like for a vote. And I'm from
Indiana. And it's like we're a red state and
I'm like everyone I fight to. I don't see
how we're race yet. I don't know how I'd like
for a vote where I've tried to do believe.
Look it up and see how that works. I understand.
The basic of it is that that state has this
many electoral votes. I kinda understand that
part. But if the majority of the
people that I see a lot of people and I know
there are a lot of people that are more Republican
by Republicans, I gitti. But at this point
is why less to do what's best for the night.
Here he is, the time three. I am just really
scared, and I thank you so much for your broadcast
and dominated town or people like me to understand.
I thank you so much. And I'll try to watch
the. So tonight are in feet. I'll try, but
sometimes we do it both at a point where you
get on a U. S. Even the all the bad stuff
that's going on around here, it's like it's
great.
All right, Linda, I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you so much. Glad you're newly politically
engaged. Very important to be doing so.
That's going to do it for calls today. As
always, sincere apologies that I was not able
to get to everybody, but we will take calls
again. That's my promise to you.